sorry Sarge Halloween is the worst
everyone's drunk wearing a mask and
carrying a fake gun plus all the girls
think they have to dress sexy I know
that is the worst please make them stop
I passed a [ __ ] tree on the way here
who wants that sex with a tree was it a
maple was it a maple going Giorno Buon
Giorno
pretty cool stume huh stem short for
costume ah all right let me guess you
are dumpy Chuck Norris no don't be wrong
Weasley no guy stopped me he put thought
into his costume and he is obviously
Miranda from Sex in the City
guys I'm Mario Batali multiple Mario
celebrity chef ginger prince of Little
Italy is he also a homeless troll doll
cuz the other guy got homeless troll
doll hey sleep Italia costume dude thank
you there's a man with impeccable taste
he bit a guy's butt off at a WNBA game
Eric Stoltz from mask I'll take it I
hope you're all well rested it's gonna
be a busy night the holding cells
completely fall I keep having to
separate Hillary Clinton and kim
jeong-hoon
what would bill say we need two
Undercovers at the DeKalb Street
warehouse party uh Boyle you're already
in costume as Joy Behar I'm Mario Batali
okay and Santiago you go with him yes
sir
damn it Santiago I know that you hate
Halloween but stick with me and I
promise you you will love it can you
magically make everyone kind sober and
fully dressed kind sober and fully
dressed good news everyone we found the
name of Santiago's sex tape attention
poisoned ghouls nope every Halloween I
dress up in an amazing costume and you
never get what I am no we get what you
are an adult man who enjoys dress-up
very funny Rosa this year that won't be
a problem because you're gonna pick my
costume miss pac-man's nipple no that's
brown how would you know that to be or
not to be auntie
Thank You Jonah bark Rod Stewart
Martha Stewart he-man Master the
universe I got it Gaye Robin Hood
[Applause]
okay parties around the corner tipster
said there'll be a huge amount of drug
activity is it costume so stiff and what
are you that smell Department never
washes themselves probably vomit hey I
got you a chocolate yeah another great
thing about Halloween chocolate Thanks
oh look Raggedy Ann is drinking vodka
right from the bottle people think if
they put on a costume they can just get
away with anything they want
Halloween is Christmas for jerks come on
ma'am no open containers why should I
listen to you bone person it's called a
skeleton it's a very common word just
put the Box away you guys are cops these
guys are cops
[Music]
what happened I thought you guys were
supposed to be at the warehouse party he
got egged some of the shell got in my
contacts and my hair and my mouth and my
bra I can't tell if that's hot or not
not hot
eggshell in my bra is not hot well it's
kind of hot boobs go in a bra up top
whoo my man well it sounds like costume
Duty is going great so great having the
best time right Amy I wish I was dead
good morning boy it's Halloween I'm
surprised you didn't put on a costume I
was going to sir but then I decided
screw that jazz well I'm the only one
who ever dresses up no one ever gets my
costume and they make fun of me so I'm
done these people don't deserve my
dress-up gifts
Charles seriously no costume what the
hell Charles where's your Halloween
spirit but you guys always make fun of
me I have never once insulted you in my
life especially these Ivy your
appearance yeah man we always loved your
costumes remember last year when you
came as that person and/or thing yes I
do remember sir permission is sprint to
my car get my emergency costume does it
matter if I say no wow
a bam bam boom where you dressed up you
look like an idiot yeah what are you
supposed to be a sassy car mechanic no
come on he's clearly the rejected
pop-tarts mascot harry pop-tart I am NOT
You Know Who I am squad that's enough
you're making boil for about on purpose
he's Elvis yes Elvis Stojko the Canadian
fingers did
you